yo you're an r b guy right so like I
think about like the dark ages of r b
that produced guys like Frank Ocean and
The Weeknd because we had this like
weird era of r b where like Neo was
doing fist pump like [__] anthems
with Pitbull and [__] Chris Brown and
Usher was saying oh my god well I am
just doing all this [__] just
terrible pop records that were all over
the [__] radio
Trey Songz didn't budge I don't remember
a Trey Songz EDM song
there might be one but Trey at that time
was doing like actually really dope r b
mixtapes for sure he was keeping
um but I feel like out of that we did
get like the Frank Ocean and the weekend
[__] at the same time it was like House
of balloons some the summer of 2011 we
got Nostalgia Ultra we got House of
balloons and we got cocaine 80s that's
that changed and then shortly after that
Miguel had some dope I mean Miguel's
album was crazy at that time oh
kaleidoscope dreams incredible
um but that was more like Channel orange
time I think what was that oh my word
are you in the first album all I wanted
you was though we had a and then I'm
saying more so like what kind of defined
the way we're talking about the blog era
when it came to r b it was Frank cocaine
80s the weekend and then Janae was
putting out her mixtapes at that time
and that I mean to me is the genre of
what this Moody dark
which I I know a lot of r b people [__]
on this new sound of r b i don't I think
r b is an amazing place and if you look
there's people that can really sing
there's people that can make really good
music there's people that can make dark
Moody whispery [__] that I like too like
it doesn't have to be defined just by
the vocalists I think we need to take
care of our vocalists
they are the unicorns and we need them
all the time but that doesn't mean we
have to [__] on everyone that can make
great records when they're Whispering I
was gonna say there's like this huge
obviously with what happened at
Coachella a lot of people were down on
Frank Ocean rightfully you know I get it
yeah for sure he [__] did a
half-assed I'm so GL I was my son's a
huge Frank Ocean fan I'm so glad I was
about to do the whole weekend I'm so
glad my tickets did not come through
because I was like you see your [__]
this is your savior on stage with a
[__] DJ doing a random set for 30
minutes in the middle Mr King what is
this is your [__] King right here but
I still love frank but I feel like Do
You Feel Like We over like like we hold
him in a higher regard than we should
based on like the amount of music that's
actually out what also tells you of
course how good that music was I mean
he's one of the few artists in this era
that did the Mystique thing so well that
we don't know his asterisks like we have
we know all of Chris Brown's Asterix we
do all but
you have to at least Chris Brown has
given us himself whether music
personally for everything for good or
bad he's constantly put music out he's
constantly performing he's constantly
trying new things like that's great
but Frank
hasn't done that and which is fine I put
out like a
fifteen thousand dollar [__] ring
okay well I mean he did entrepreneur he
put out a piece of Dick jewelry
entrepreneur was interesting this year
um but I have a weird weird thoughts on
that too because I think we still need
those few mysterious artists like I
still like that because I grew up in
that era where it was like you didn't
know the artist and it gave you an album
and they disappeared for three years and
they came back like that's ill if you
can do that now and Frank has a master
class in that regard but it makes
moments like Coachella super magnified
if it's not good and you deserve all the
critique you get from it because you
only pop up every now and then so when
you pop up you have to make it your best
like we waited forever from Channel
orange to blonde he delivered on blonde
he kept that mystique and that Legend
going so when you're about to do
Coachella we assume if you're going to
do Coachella you've been rehearsing for
a year you don't pop out unless it's
gonna be something yeah you would expect
like this is gonna be insane and I
assume that there'd be music with it
like if you're gonna pop out and do
something drop it I don't think Frank is
is low on money I don't I mean I don't
know his habits I think the cockering
probably did well I don't know did he
partner with Bluetooth I don't know
maybe I hope that promo code like three
months Supply it's just when you when
you disappear and have that luxury of
Disappearing and having so much so much
anticipation when you just tweet hey
right you have to deliver when it's time
to and he did not deliver so nah he
deserves the critique he's gotten he's a
legend in my opinion when it comes to
music he's one of my favorite do you
like but I mean I love Channel orange
blonde was one of those ones that had to
grow on me it grew on me I I didn't like
blonde when it first came out almost
like season two of The Wire you know
sure that's a all right I'm not mad at
that comparison you know you watch
season two who are these [__] white
dudes at the [__] Pier you know like
oh no I love season two of The Wire now
like
um blonde initially I didn't hate but I
wasn't a huge fan of it as the years
went it's one of the best written albums
I think what I got to my like late 20s
around like 29 almost probably going to
30 I was like this is this is the
definition of someone transitioning from
their 20s to their 30s right like the
writing on that album is [__]
incredible it's a rap album like almost
down to what scissor did with SOS of
just like how much her pen is all over
that crazy the way Solange they would
see it at the table where it's just like
this isn't just r b there's so much
[__] words and content in this right
it's not just Melody driven it's not
drum driven it this is a pen blonde is
that to me it's one of the best written
albums I've ever heard but it took me
years to get there yeah I feel like
because you're just you just expect
something different there's not a wasted
syllable on blonde and it took me a
while to to realize that
um coming off Channel orange give me a
snare like what the [__] right right and
he gave us Knights oh no no Knights did
come out with it but that was the one
that they pushed
and that was the first one we heard so I
assume the rest of I would be like
Knights and I was like I have not heard
a [__] kick yet right but it's it's a
classic